If, as I, you are afraid of spiders, you have three solutions.
One, run!
Two, kill the beast.
Three, master your fear.
First thing you must not forget, who's the boss?
You, big, strong, and armed.
The spider, little,...
...yes little, helpless and scared to death.
Second thing, don't let your emotions overwhelm you.
Jerk.
Third advice, be friendly.
Offer her a gift.
What the?
Something suitable for spiders.
Apply the Batman technique.
To master your fear, you must become your fear.
Five, sing her a song.
Six, hold it in your hand.
I said hold it in your hand!
Seven, and last but not least, if the spider disappears, don't panic!
If you know any other tips, please leave a comment or a video response,...
...and tell me what is your phobia so I can make another seven tips video out of it.